do you think women lack femininity today
and is that in this way
okay you guys you guys have to let me
finish
it's my show
okay like i have something
do you guys think
do you guys think women lack femininity
today and is that something you look for
when you're looking for a partner
tag you're it
i want to i want to hit your
tag position there you go
do women lack femininity um
i'm gonna say blankly i'm not gonna say
a blanket yes but i do think a lot of
women have
forgotten how to use their sexual wilds
to get things from men your grandparents
and probably your parents would have
known to do things as well that's one
thing
and wait can you repeat that sorry i
think i said i'm not going to use a
blanket statement and say all women have
lost your femininity that's quite the
case but i think a lot of you have a lot
of you chasing this whole boss babe
thing and
that aggressive sort of nature that
comes with being a boss bae don't really
work for men that's one thing and i also
think a lot of you lost how to
the subtle art of using your sexual
wilds to get what you want from sexual
wear agreed
have you have you not seen girls on only
fans no no that's one of those
[Music]
sexual worlds
so
and the only fans you're not exactly
getting to have sex with a woman you're
just they're you're paying to watch them
present themselves on them
there are ways that we can support speak
to men to get things that are men
that
you should have an example should we do
that though like it's not absolutely
correct
didn't like that first of all
so for example
you can say to me a.d can't put the bins
out you say to me baby the bins are a
bit rough
[Music]
and a lot of women have forgotten how to
do that especially nowadays a lot of you
forgot no you know what those sort of
things
and that's where you've that's why i
think it's because where feminism went
because
there was like a time where feminism was
like okay a woman has to be like a man
to be respected and women really kind of
like started owning that and becoming a
lot more like men stopped dressing
feminine started wearing suits to be
respected like men i think that's
probably where that mindset probably
comes from is like lose the femininity
become more masculine and get respected
so i think that's where that lies i
think it's like women trying to find
equality and that going down this route
but like now we know like maybe it's
probably not the right route i agree
with that but so in a bit in the
business world in the work world that
may work for you but it doesn't work for
the relationship world because everyone
yeah when someone was act like a man
why'd i not just get a man
yeah
i'm a masculine person i'm just saying
that just playing out there i agree i i
completely agree because of course if
you're looking at it from a perspective
of like
a woman has to like back in the day the
woman knew like you know oh
the way we do for somebody like you the
way you're talking and stuff like that
it's like oh baby or the honey whatever
like you know you used that type of like
you're sitting at home now
now now nowadays from what i've seen it
was it was more like a table hey yo like
you some some girls like um tomboys
right two like breasts they talk like
brilliant like for real like happy like
so for example sometimes i'll be
speaking to you like i've seen i've seen
uh i know one of my friends um i'm kind
of megan right
because i always i always really enjoy
like
i i just tend to enjoy things that guys
like and i'm not really into like makeup
but i still think you still have a
feminine element like i still found you
but if the right guy if the right guy
walked by right
i think you can do a lot with the eyes i
think hair playing is a bit you know
yeah but i think you're kind of flirty
with everyone i feel like i'm just being
nice i mean i think it's just my it's
just how i am yeah i know i know it's
like feminine though oh okay
that's why that's why i call you
masculine yeah i think it's just weird
because like for like since i was little
i was always like the tomboy like i had
like you know i had an older brother i'd
literally like
this fight with them yeah
i feel like every woman at a certain
stage went through that tomboy stage
though
no as i said i feel like i feel like at
a certain point we might have been a
long term but i feel like every girl at
some point has got has been or will go
through like a tomboy stage-ish
i think it's just like pre-progressing
because like everyone like proof person
isn't really like doesn't really go into
their gender that like i feel like the
gender roles or the gender types aren't
that distinct i think femininity and
masculinity isn't that strong in like
kindergarten or like in like middle
school like when children are quite
young you don't really like okay he's
acting very masculine or acting very
feminine then that comes when you grow
and mature
ladies so is it is is femininity a bad
thing i think femininity is great i feel
like a woman should embrace her
femininity and i feel like it's a shame
that we went through that phase that
women had to try and be like men to be
respected i feel like it's a shame that
we had to
like hide a femininity to have that kind
of respect because it is true like a
very feminine woman isn't respected the
same way
like just in the workplace in general
like in a professional world like a
woman's very feminine like oh she's a
blonde she's not very smart i don't i
haven't had like i've found that girls
that are feminine in the workplace get
more favors from men
but that's at the cost of i don't think
this woman is intelligent enough to do
that by herself it's like i'm gonna help
her and slept with no not really like
because i just was and the only girl in
an office of like 25 people and when i
was working there the guys that were
kind of on the same like job as me they
would always tell me
that um i only got help with certain
things because i was a girl and at first
i kind of was like yeah whatever
but in hindsight like
kind of because all the managers would
like help me with whatever i wanted like
drop everything
do special like one-on-one time they
would ask for the same thing and be like
weeks
yeah can i ask you girls a question
right would you respect a man that's
like feminine and it's open open about
like his feelings like he's not he's not
afraid to like oh open about your
feelings he's not feminine no but i'm
saying like he's like sorry okay
would you would you be like do you
respect a man that's like open about
like his feelings and like he would he's
like not ashamed to like cry in front of
you and supply and stuff like that would
be like no no
no exactly yes that's the only thing
i'm sorry look at it look at my mind is
like open like oh no not not a degree
where he's like you're like you know
what he's capable of but like in front
of you like he's he's open about his
feelings like you know he's not afraid
to cry something you know i mean
i've been in a situation like that it
was just exhausting so i was like you
have so many feelings
okay
flip flip flip that on us yeah but when
you girls give us stuff and we just have
to sit there and we'd be like i support
you darling like
i think a lot of people that i mean like
i would say like you're pretty like i'd
say in touch with your emotions but
you're not like very emotional like you
know you're not like crying all over
yeah you know i would say like i'm all
public that way like i'm not i'm very i
keep everything inside and so like if i
were to have to deal with someone that's
very open about it i feel like that
would be a lot for me to deal with too i
think it just depends on how that person
also expresses it i think there's i
think there's a difference between being
emotionally unavailable like to a toxic
like extent like the point like okay
like this person's giving really mixed
signals this person doesn't know how to
act like a human being
then to being okay like i don't want to
express my emotions all the time like
sometimes i don't need to cry right now
sometimes but it's not a big deal
sometimes you can you know like work
through things it's not always about
expressing emotions and like big bits of
rage or being like too angry or those
kind of things i think it's about
balance like
having the bare minimum is expressing
your emotions i'm happy i'm sad i like
this i enjoy this like being direct then
there's a difference between completely
hiding your emotions so that the woman's
like are you actually okay so there's
something wrong like always to keep
guessing i don't think that's a positive
but
what would you say would that be like um
like a red flag for some girls i think
it's a red flag if a man can't openly
talk about um what he's feeling i'm
saying to a girl like if a man's
actually like
is not afraid to express his feelings
you know you're all emotional and stuff
like do you think someone goes that
would be like a red flag i mean i think
for some people maybe but i feel like
for me no i think it'd be quite
refreshing to have a guy express his
emotions if he's happy like i'm happy
like it doesn't have to be always about
something sad it can be like oh like i
really appreciate what you did today or
i really support you or like oh i got
frustrated when you did that can we talk
about this can we talk about about that
like it doesn't always have to be like
oh a guy cried because his mom died like